So six seven. Last year. Yeah yeah yeah. J.k. Mcfarlane mc. If a r a n g. If you can. My name is jan.
I worked during the aquarius testable. For the aquarius foundation. I went away for five years.
And then i came back and had children. And haven't really gone anywhere. I now manage a local business.
My name's jay and. I also worked on a query yes first of all.
At the end of the first i want to run away as far as a coup.
Somehow ended up back here again and i have my own business. Within the terms. Golly.
The truth the whole truth and nothing. But i can write. Accidentally accidentally.
If things are merely accidents and if that's the case.
But i had already been in north queensland for about eighteen months after dropping out of sydney.
And came back to sydney because at first when you leave the city you don't know how to survive really.
And my skills were coming quite slowly and so i had to do a couple of four eyes back to the city.
And i'm one of them are running to my friend precious who said.
We're going to name of course for you what for so he explained about the festival and. What was likely to happen and.
We want to come and work our source and sitting with a friend of mine. And so we said yes and.
We again went back to queens and then came. Specially to work on the first. In the january.
So just we were we were very idealistic then incredibly idealistic as well as. Fairly footloose and fancy for a no.
If something sounds exciting. Because we weren't employed. We could just go there and.
Fairly feel a sense both in those ties to a lot of carriage around. Well i had just returned home from india and.
I was in a spot of trouble i suppose you could say. And it was a way out. And i had friends that were living here and.
So i disappeared. And made myself very scarce. I was there i came here and.
Moved into a band with a number of people being one of them.
And we worked on setting up the rainbow cafe which was really good fun. We did used to spend a lot of time.
Culling one another. Playing you cooking and cuddling priorities.
Was one of the biggest features of the festival was the amount of cuddling and.
It was definitely in the days of flower power.
And end of life solution we went to lasting each other because everybody would catch it straightaway.
And i really truly. I saw it for the truck to come in from brisbane and. The truck driver who was a little bit.
Sly used to call out in the middle of the street hive. You want to go running.
But everyone would be infected again like i think.
I traveled all over india and never caught me and i couldn't play
but they would be virtually jumping off a name for being so i mean really there were gross.
You know you experienced them before the recent brushes and you know. They were using here with me.
Funky i think you can see. Well everyone was very into hair which. Your bones. Was a terrible example.
But it was a great deal of fun. There's a lot of. Lovely sharing lots of campfires and. Music and.
Management was it right from going because most of us come out of. Nuclear family isolation.
So this was where it was really at. And it was around the time when actually it was discovery.
Being discovered on a large scale with young people and so there was an enormous amount of heart opening.
And people thought that this was the best thing that ever happened and. Turned in.
I think a lot of people have said to me that it was a turning point in their lives.
And that their attitudes changed at that point in time and massively related.
New attitudes that maybe they have used as a basis for how they've conducted themselves from here on in a lot of group
a lot of things done in circles. A lot of sharing.
I think also taking my friends together and story telling lots of story telling and
and finding value in your own story.
Which i think what's so great about what you're doing because it does it gives value to people's lives to hear their
own stories. And it also gives value to your life when you stop and look at why you've done. Things or not may.
Makes a special focus think it's great stuff. I am so very much.
And there were a lot of evenings held at the rainbow cafe were with people who were involved in the setting up of the
festival who would get up and sing. And encourage others to sing so there was a lot of that sort of.
Group sharing that.
Maybe people hadn't really experienced that we first i said we came out of new families i mean obviously a lot of
people had experience before they came here.
But by and large i think we were city people with very little experience of that extended sharing we had.
Maybe communal households in sydney but you didn't tend to meet in really large groups of people
and was a big part of a lot of people getting stoned together and taking mushrooms and.
I suppose mind expansion in a sense. Before it became. Dreary and it was a real space where you could play.
Yeah you know i could it was like. Revisiting childhood we've often talked about this and realize the value.
There was great worth in that because we did have a we took the time we were given the time just to reconnect with all
my friends. Over a period of months and basically we just played. We had the best firm. Even if. Yeah.
New skills because we set up the right. We set up the craft center.
And then on wind who worked on the offset printing press which i'd never considered before.
You know and had a fight with mentor. Which we were paid a dollar a day which is just to print the money.
And if you've been given to you could base everybody and now.
I remember one day buying nothing to feed fifty thousand rice. Spread dollars. And i thought you know.
You got a dollar a day for working on the festival. But we printed. And you know. I don't even have one. You know.
Michael was asking. Oh i've never even heard of them.
We never even got to keep them you know i mean that's all the money we had we had no social you know this is now you're
actually cured and we have you know i don't want to die i was really viable. And so you never got to.
If you want yeah we did something we had a truck a big truck that we got to brisbane and bought by the market.
So that was the convention that a number of the said with the truckie his name is harry.
Who had grown up in an old people's home and used to tell the most amazing stories he was very old man himself and.
He was a young man but he talked like a really old man.
And he would talk literally from the moment you left him into the until he got to prison and all the way back.
So we would jockey for position. And we took frightfully slow. And if you was still me time to go.
I think one of them just died the other day a man named dudley who was a fairly old man to talk me down
and roger the man that runs this guy i mean. Yeah no no no no no no don't look at an old man with white hair that.
Time. I mean. Roger came after the first one hundred years in the back you know he started yeah he studied the craft.
After scrying. So by the time the festival came around we had a stablished. Quite a strong bond between people.
Considering how many people worked on the setting up of it i think and.
The arguments were very minimal really that was pretty good feeling amongst them.
Was a feeling like an extended family the bond that we lived in i guess there would have been fifteen.
Maybe even more some of. They were little tiny piece sheds and.
Own cow bells which we had all turned into homes and people had put up tents and things and.
That was just one portion of it there were a lot of i sort of was it like to call the magic circle. On my.
Given the job of sewing. A dozen i think take a piece out of canvas. For the chorus foundation which we did.
And for doing that to keep the center. Down in the magic circle we actually moved out of this.
Hut that we stand shooting and. So there are lots of. You know looked into. Term housing and.
Lots of alternative healing. You know hollow tree down in the paddock down here.
And they went they have moved away from there they're going to live in.
And she eventually started the bath and beyond and.
Their beginnings were as acupuncturists this holiday tree was pretty airy fairy very cosmic it much of the time you
know it's make. Yes mostly night. And loaded. Like a risk. It will never come again.
I mean even the children who i see in the street now who are trying to recreate it through their dress and.
And maybe some of their ideals. I don't think it can ever be like that again because there's a certain.
Innocence is lost in that we have game show for the children. I do it's well. I think it's great for.
I feel at that point in our lives and. We were very optimistic.
And there was a heart that things would get better because it was.
As i said the flower power days and people were out i'm an optimistic that. Society would.
As we knew it would break down and out of that would come a new order and possibly a much better attitude towards.
Planet and towards one another as. People and. In england it's a question i want science to apes.
I just think we're a bit slow on the uptake i'm just saying. Great need.
Not so much now for the tourism which people have been really focusing on.
But for the children things for the children to foxes for them and.
Fun for them because right around advanced down the human ground and. We have a great time together.
One hundred fifty children pass through their week. Maybe preschool. Classes ones. And that's from two used to sixteen.
So we have time. I would say. I feel that there's a lot of. Rich a sense about celebrating aquarius.
In a state the town is in which is sad because it's such a worry. To most of the people that live here that.
I don't feel helpless.
Because we basically have this tended to see tolerance as sort of like a catch phrase
and it always has been since the days
when we first came here because if you think about the old settlers that lived here.
In this very quiet area and a bunch of crazy hippies with the banner hanging out their trousers literally.
Moved in on them and i am a very tolerant of us and.
A lot of those people have stayed and have become long time residents and.
Have a good relationship with the old residents in the town.
But the new young kids there or the new wave of paper that is new and with the ass hanging out of their trousers.
Who are using drugs and selling them on the streets. Residents really out there terrified. At that and not.
Under whether or not the streets safe and that's not nice. I mean. That's out tolerance gone haywire.
But basically we don't know what to do about and i certainly don't know any such thing as many suggested today.
Doesn't sound right like the police coming in dealing with it mcadam aloft and you think well.
Where are they going to go for them. But i don't i mean i come here because of the tongue. Front. But it's.
It's kind of turned against us really innocence which is very sad. And that's why i think it's sad.
Altogether is that lack of. Loss of innocence because that's been the outcome of that state.
Well again it could come back to a focus on facilities for these people if they're going to be here to do with in some
way that helps. And. It's just cast them out further. Just gets harder and harder.
Maybe a little creative approach to it but. Once again. You know that would take some body of.
Responsible people to take that and funding. And from the funding. Because we're not much richer. And financially.
Richer in spirit but still you know.
It's still a pocket of idealism when it comes to that because i mean a lot of people ended up on communities
and built their own homes and live fairly low cost lives yes we do. We certainly do and.
We know lots of people like that. Yeah. And that feels great.
And that's the way that we do with being able to settle for a much lower income.
Is because we've got a much less costly. Wakely you know i mean it's just we've set up. That sort of lifestyle.
So we don't draw on. Too much resource and the planet. You know it's true that when they were i have of being.
Making breakfast in the rain one morning i was making on letts
and a friend of mine came in with a box of a hat full of freshly picked gold tops which he then put into my own let me
stand. Which we all i hate and we were in the process of making him graffitti or at the back. Spinning it was me me me.
And i got him.
I was speeding and i was so i larded i couldn't by the end of it i can be a scrap i think i'm going to go home ok.
But i can say long you got to do but it grows. Blowing the puntland back to something. That was good for him.
Also i remember a friend of ours who was pregnant this might just be after aquarius. And she was very pregnant and.
She was playing in the creek down the bottom of the magic circle down the creek and she stood on a stone. Fish.
And you know what if you know that he does pull round. And she screws rein in the sector to treat effect on.
And she was carried by friend of mine as is about six foot three the whole length the road
and up to ten to the hospital. Screaming headlines at one point to him her nearly had a big fat blubbery woman scream.
Yeah that was fun remember that. I also remember. Going with a whole bunch of us in the truck.
To a country dance right out in the middle of nowhere i wouldn't to this day know where i was.
And it was all the old timers having abandoned said we were invited and.
It was the most beautiful night they danced and sang dances and then gave us all scones and. He and i was just.
Well i've never seen anything quite like it but we have actually.
Through the connections in the past some very good friends of the older residents in the town.
Because they weren't such a great many of us.
At the beginning and members of the horsemen and i remember going to the rices with jewels and precious and.
Before we went to the races we thought we better get some good clothes into something nice.
And we found these three a match and we'd all at that point in time cut her hair off like short.
And we all called ourselves bruce and when. Pinstripes ships.
I just thought it was great these are always cry to introduce us to everybody in boston had the best time.
We didn't even on the roll call bruce. That's really funny. But used to be. Music in the pub.
In the front by the pub here and we did used to dance. We often.
Been dry so it's kind of a uniform and they were all blotched with paint and embroider things and.
We would dance with the local fellas and i thought that was great i thought all the christmas is coming.
Nationally that you could have really good concerts in the town.
Because it was the one company that was right from place to just come up with all sorts of amazing things.
Breaking new ground in her and. So that was excellent. We still have some very nice time.
But it was just on the part of the crazy right. The magic circle. Was just this very beautiful bend in the creek.
And it my quarter. Like a semicircle. And then meandered on so when. Put there.
It was like a little circle and in the center was a big. Trench for the. Cooking finance and.
You just used the water from the creek it was just very nice place
and of course everyone would see transplanted willingness and was just it was a magic so.
There was a sauna down there and.
So we would have hot sun as and then making the creek and that's when we were doing something like that.
And again just everywhere there was music. I remember in my it was quite cold and the mists would come up.
Because there's lots of creeks through here. At the back.
And the miss would come off
and you'd be stumbling because hardly anybody even owned a torch you know we didn't know you know anything much at all.
And you'd be stumbling through the mist.
Just missing the creek or falling over somebody would fall and how it was very funny. And you coming to these.
Tense situations or just you know however people had saved up some sort of shelter.
And little tiny lights and then you discover all the faces and maybe music happening
and i remember there was one lovely one over there and that guy was there who had made all these musical instruments.
The craziest musical instruments you know where you sort of have to stretch the necks of things. And wonderful.
That was one of the best places to go out knife. It was really fun.
So the first record stayed on for us and after a short period of time and then i went to northern queensland. Yeah.
That we started to help the club. I started to log a stall so my friend joel was having a baby. He was born in july.
She was for me and. We waited until. Big enough to travel back to queensland. When you returned.
About sixteen years ago. Maybe fifteen years ago. And i had been living in tunisia and. America and japan and.
I came back to a strange you know wanting to settle and have children and.
The only place i thought that was going was named because the midwife who i spoke about that lived in the hollow tree.
Had since become a midwife and i knew that's what i wanted to do.
So i came back and headed straight for naman and they were friends of mine and we lived in and. One of the original.
Five houses in newman. I don't know how rich smith road.
Belonged to one of the original settlers and in many areas the most magnificent old scow and we came back.
And i taught about a coyote and about take studio for the. Very fast since then i go.
Every now and again they are just children children and. To microsoft you know we built a house.
We live in the community. So.
I think my husband
and i lived in about seven places around in a number of them one of them was on a community with graeme dunstan
and at the time his wife died. And their children.
So that was the early days when people were beginning to have their babies at home there was a very. Being.
Well once again i think that idealist. Attitude towards. Having babies at home building homes.
Going veggie gardens and orchards. That was very viable thing to do.
And i think there was something like two hundred babies born in the area that we would often attend one another's
births sometimes i would go with carol. Climbing mountains in the middle of the night as her birthing assistance.
There was a still even in those days who was most fantastic failing in this town. We had it.
A folk club that people would come from far and wide to be a paddle. And it was just wonderful.
Because to dollar to get in and people who you wouldn't even know where performance would get up
and just surprise you with my spew. Is really good fun.
And even in those days i think it was still very hard to get sense of social security so there was a lot of sharing
people would share. You know they was. There was a lot of sharing. That took place.
Well the start of the hunger movement. Carol elliott who was a trained acupuncturist.
And very interested in homeopathy.
Who had had four children has so i think she's since a qualified midwife and she went to london
and got her qualifications but at the time she was and i midwife.
And she would go to people whose place is very inaccessible.
Like i mean i remember one birth she went to right at the end of the guard's valley.
And it was during a whip season and the lady couldn't get out. And so carolyn. And then norman waded the creek and.
It was one of those extended labors and so basically they would just go to people's homes and i would set up camp and.
Sometimes i'd be there for days and. You know people would have their babies the way they wanted to.
Which was very soft lighting. Ambience that you weren't harried. My first child was born. That it.
Explained in the fam has a carolyn moment and i lived in the labor was very easy. Six hours.
I had people sitting in the room meditating. He was born in the us.
Well it blighted started in the early hours of the morning his phone and lunchtime and it was just.
No hurry nobody has identity lot of reading
and i think that was the thing most women who had had their babies in harm really took responsibility for educating
themselves about the purses so.
Even i didn't know what to expect i basically knew what was going to happen and carol's very telepathic woman.
She would just do it here. And she would just read you. And you know what next. Yeah.
Thank you again you know why pendulum of your family to see where you were at at what stage in your life over
and you know she give you some homeopathic said she would basically just talk about and do what she had to do and.
When the birth was over you don't drink champagne and. A chocolate cake or fruit cake was a favorite.
Had to beg for her but she did in fact deliver. Many of the children that people. Gave names to like rain forest and.
Softly saw my sensical just seeing right. And very beautiful children and in those days.
Everyone was having babies that was a really big baby boom here and so there was a lot of communal living and.
With small children and we would start play groups together and. Bicyclists share as much or.
Well she worked on a donation basis and.
Unfortunately that's where things really went wrong i feel because she was often people would come from a long way away
to have their baby and i would end up staying with carolyn and.
They wouldn't have much in the way of money so that either pay her with cabbages or. You know about a something and.
They eventually got to the point where carolyn and we couldn't live like that anymore.
And after having that happen to them for years on end. They felt that they she didn't have to.
No it had to be on the dole. Doing what they were doing. And in any other place they wouldn't have had that. Abuse.
Unfortunately it did become difficult for them. So they ended up going to live in london and.
Can very well known very famous it. Has meant a lot of money. But it was done on about a system really. I think.
Well that's right. You know it's going to be the best in best my second child i think it was a room.
Maybe it's because this room here which is what twelve. By ten and. There were eighteen people five somewhat children.
My eldest son jesse was a birth attendant he looked.
I mean he couldn't get any closer he gave a running commentary like. Yak money.
Yeah yeah yeah everybody in fits of laughter.
And my brother and i took photos
and he would have been right maybe almost between my legs i mean he got the most explicit birth notice.
And i didn't even notice him. There were people everywhere.
And it was just you know as you say it's like birth planning.
But it was so personal and so intense that it really didn't matter.
And each and every one of those people has a connection with my children unless they've got to be present.
We just had a birth recently on the broad. Most recent and. Marilyn's eldest son. Fifteen and.
It's about this baby kind of sitting at the bottom of the bit saying this is not my mother's best feature.
There are things like that room again.
You know like it's so you just get drawn there you know you think you need these people will come
but they hadn't has the baby come you know. You know on the energy.
That you can't do that but i think it was the home with so many circle around. And quite a few.
Yes all the kids who went to school the next stage. Personal development class and said.
Experience best personal development we've ever had you had a baby. Yeah. It's one.
And then we would have blessing ceremonies there was one absolutely beautiful
when we were on fact there's been many of them when max.
Visited this area because that's another thing that people a lot of people around this area into meditation of some
sort and so we get. Incredible visits from very high. Spiritual beings and on a couple of occasions we've had them. Do.
Naming ceremonies for children with people from farm wod would bring their babies and.
They would be given a spiritual name and then there'd be a celebration and a blessing and a very beautiful.
Let me tell you that night at the post office and you know. I remember mr smith.
Mr smith who used to run the post office and him and he was a saint he was ready for a time
and so he figured he would buy himself the smallest postoffice he could find and retired to.